This video is sponsored by Notion.
While most of us access the internet through
a wireless device, a physical link is still
required.
My website is hosted on a server in North
America.
If you’re viewing this on another continent,
your internet provider has almost certainly
used a cable under the sea to retrieve the
data.
Lines just a tad thicker than a garden hose
crisscross the ocean, zipping data from LA
to Chile faster than the time it takes to
finish this sentence.
These things are absolute marvels of engineering.
This isn’t your grandparents’ twisted
pair of copper wire from the telephone pole
to the house.
There are more than 400 lines in service stretching
over 1.3 million km or 800,000 miles.
Enough to go around the world 32 times.
Data travels as pulses of light inside the
cables' optical fibers before arriving at
a landing station where it continues its journey
overland.
Laying cables isn’t new and dates back to the 1800s.
The first transatlantic telegraph cable allowed
Queen Victoria to send a message to U.S.
President James Buchanan in 1858, opening
up a new era in global communication.
During the Cold War, an American nuclear submarine
secretly listened in when the Soviets used
an underwater cable to communicate between
a naval base and its mainland.
Today, modern cables carry digital data, including
internet traffic.
And many of these have recently been funded
by tech companies which now own or lease
well over half of the availability bandwidth.
Facebook and Google are working with regional
telecommunications providers to invest in
a new line called Echo to connect the US with
Asia.
The tech giants may share the cable, but they’ll
have their own designated fiber pairs within
it.
Kind of like having your own lane on a multi-lane
highway.
So, why are tech companies laying their own
cables?
They used to lease bandwidth from telecom
providers like AT&T who were the major investors
in building cables.
But now, they’re opting to build their own
pipes to meet the surge in demand for their
services - from YouTube, to Spotify, to cloud
computing.
By building lines themselves, they have greater
control over the infrastructure.
Hurricane Sandy was the wake-up call.
The superstorm that hit the US east coast
in 2012 damaged an area that hosts a significant
number of cable landing points, disrupting
communication for days.
Facebook and Microsoft realized it wasn’t
the best idea to have the cables clustered
in New York and New Jersey.
So, they partnered with telecommunications
infrastructure company Telxius to design a
line further south - opting to make Virginia
Beach the starting point for a new connection
to Spain.
When Marea went operational in 2019, it provided
the fastest transatlantic internet connection
ever - transferring 160 terabits of data every
second - equivalent to streaming 71 million HD movies at the same time.
The capacity on these cables is just enormous, it’s nothing like we’ve seen three, four years ago.
Used to be you’d build a cable and there might be four fiber pairs on the cable.
Now it’s routine for these new cables to come online with like 16 fiber pairs.
Tech giants are also choosing to fund the
project entirely themselves.
Google announced in June it’s building a
private cable called Firmina running from
the U.S. to South America, which it says will
be the longest line in the world.
By building privately, Google can decide exactly
where to build routes to best suit its needs.
For example, it can minimize the distance
between its data centers which then reduces
delay known as latency.
It can connect remote parts of the world.
Or reinforce an area with limited lines.
Google has built six cables on its own dime
and has funded 16 projects overall.
Tech giants that already wield significant
influence are likely to own more of the internet
backbone in the future.
Kind of like if Amazon owned the roads where
packages are delivered.
I think the concern is that the big content
providers would form some sort of monopoly
on international bandwidth but they're not sellers of bandwidth, right?
Like, they deploy it and use it themselves.
These companies fork over hundreds of millions
of dollars to build the infrastructure which
can take years.
You won’t see cables at the beach because
they’re buried below the seabed.
In the deep sea, large ships lay them on the
ocean floor, sometimes 8,000 meters or 26,000
ft below - as deep as Mount Everest is high.
The actual wires inside that carry the bits
of code are merely the width of a human hair
while the cable is much thicker, consisting
of layers of protection.
Still, some hazards are unavoidable.
In 2016, a fishing trawler is believed to
have severed a cable in Africa, taking the
whole of the west African country of Mauritania
offline for two days and impacting nine other
nations.
And in 2013, authorities in Egypt accused
three scuba divers of trying to cut a cable
in the Mediterranean sea.
Repairing a line can take weeks.
A specially equipped ship is dispatched to
the region, pulls up the cable in the right
spot, makes the repair, before bringing it
back down.
When possible, multiple lines covering the
same route are laid to prevent disruptions.
Besides broken cables, there are also security
concerns.
In 2020, Washington blocked the portion of
Facebook and Google’s planned cable linking
the U.S. to Hong Kong over fears of spying because
one of the other backers was majority-owned
by a Chinese telecom company.
Similarly, in 2018, Australia prevented the
Chinese company Huawei from funding a new
cable to Papua New Guinea and the Solomon
Islands over fears China could use the
technology to spy on the West which Huawei
has denied.
Even if countries thwart efforts to build
cables, the need for greater data capacity
still exists.
And satellites can’t handle the demand.
SpaceX may be creating a high-speed satellite
internet service, however, Starlink
doesn’t have enough bandwidth to operate
in dense urban areas and will mainly serve
rural regions.
So, undersea cables are still the most reliable
way to transmit information to the greatest
number of people over large distances.
There’s another way to stay connected.
When I work with my team, we share ideas,
plan, and stay organized all in one place
using Notion.
We’ve created a page prioritizing all of
the tasks.
On another page, we’ve mapped out the outline
of a future video.
You can personalize the pages however you
like.
I’ve also got a private workspace with my
own To-Do list and various notes to help me
stay on track.
I first tried Notion when they approached
me about sponsoring a video and now, I can’t
imagine my life without it.
Everything is in one place, on one app, that
I can access on my computer or my phone.
If you’d like to give Notion a try - whether
to use it for yourself or to collaborate with
others - you can sign up with the link in
my description.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.